the first question you tend to get asked
when you meet someone at a parties so
what do you do and according to how
impressive your answer is people are
either really keen to get to know you
better
or swiftly leave you behind by the nuts
we're anxious because we live in a world
of snobs people who take a tiny part of
us our professional identities and use
these to come to a complete verdict
about how valuable we are as humans the
opposite of a snob is your mother she
doesn't care about your status she cares
about your soul yet most people aren't
our mothers and that's why we worry so
much about judgment and humiliation it
said we live in materialistic times but
it's more poignant than that we live in
times where emotional rewards have been
pegged to the acquisition of material
things what people want when they go
after money big jobs or fancy cars is
rarely the things in themselves so much
as the attention and respect if you like
the love that are given to those who
have them next time you see a guy
driving by in a Ferrari don't think it's
someone unusually greedy think it's
someone with a particularly intense
vulnerability and need for love
we're also anxious because we're
constantly told that we could become
anything we hear it from our earliest
days it should be great that there's so
much opportunity in the modern world but
what if we fail in such a world what if
you don't manage to get to the top when
they were said to be every chance the
self-help shelves of bookstores are
filled with two kinds of books that
capture the modern anxious condition the
first half titles like how to make it
big in 15 minutes or be an overnight
millionaire the second half titles like
how to cope with low self-esteem the two
genres are related a society that tells
people they could have everything but
we're in fact only a tiny minority can
will end up with a lot of
dissatisfaction and grief there's a
related problem our societies are to a
large extent deemed to be fair back in
the olden days you knew the system was
totally rigged it wasn't your fault if
you were a peasant and not to your
credit if you were the Lord but now
we're told our societies of
meritocracies places where the rewards
go to those who really merit them
the hard-working clever among us it
sounds lovely but there's a nasty sting
in the tail if you really believe in a
society where those at the top deserve
to get there that has to mean that those
at the bottom deserve to be there to
meritocracies make poverty seem not just
unpleasant but also somehow deserved in
medieval England people used to call the
poor unfortunates literally people who
had not been blessed by the goddess of
fortune nowadays especially in the
United States when meritocracy is big
they call them rather tellingly losers
we scarcely believe in luck nowadays
anymore as something that can explain
where we end up no one will believe you
if you say you were fired because of bad
luck your professional position has
become the central verdict on your
character
no wonder suicide rates rise
exponentially the moment of society
joins the so-called modern world how can
we cope well first off by refusing to
believe that any society really ever can
be meritocratic lark or accident
continue to determine a critical share
of where people end up in the hierarchy
treat no one not least yourself as
though they entirely deserve to be where
they are secondly make up your own
definition of success instead of
uncritically leaning on societies there
are so many ways to succeed and many of
them have nothing to do with status as
it's currently defined within the value
system of industrial capitalism those
who succeed at making money rarely
succeed at empathy or family life
thirdly and most importantly we should
refuse to let our outer achievements
define our sense of self entirely there
remain so many vital sides of us that
will never appear on our business cards
that don't stand a chance of being
captured by that maddeningly blunt and
unimaginative question so what do you do
you